[Music]  this is my ex-girlfriend Justin Bieber  dishing on his Selena Gomez tattoo back  in 2016 so I kind of try to cover face  up but did some shading but people still  know yeah we definitely still know and  ink is still visible even though we  popped the question the Haley Baldwin  over the weekend  check out the Biebs in NYC on Tuesday  his angel inspired Selena ink is hard to  miss on his left wrist you can also see  a glimpse of it and these Instagram pics  he posted confirming his engagement no  word on if he plans to take a trip to  the tattoo parlor to change it but a  source told DT this week that Selena  isn't upset over her ex's engagement  quote Selena is in such a great place  Justin and Haley's happiness doesn't  take away from her own happiness I feel  like you could be able to see it in my  face and I love what I'm doing right now  it's enjoying my life and I'm getting to  do things that I'm passionate about with  the people that I love  [Music]  [Applause]